that's right it's time for drew's news
and if news were bagels
we try to be the everything and with me
at the desk is
my toasty lol sesame seed ross matthew
hi hi everybody hi drew
you are a delightful topping aren't you
if i had a nickel thank you all right
we're going to kick it off with
broadway because we've got the news
we've all been waiting for
forbes reports that smash hits hamilton
wicket and the lion king are all
officially reopening on
september 14th and right behind them
yes right behind these icons
is also some super fresh new exciting
shows
six very exciting this is a huge play
uh about henry the eighth wives
oh wow um yeah and this is like the it
show and it's finally coming to new york
on september 17th there's so much buzz
about
it it's bananas um you've got one to
tear
talk about well mrs doubtfire hello
drive by fruiting
uh it's in previews on october 21st we
can't wait to see that uh
the music man with hugh jackman will
finally start previews
and sutton foster yes side note i was at
dinner the other night and hugh jackman
was
right over there i know oh my god a hugh
jackman side
that's a good one right yeah yeah i was
so nervous um there's also
beetlejuice um dear evan hansen's coming
back
well it's so exciting because you know
broadway is so important
and it's just been the city has just
felt so empty without it without the
energy of it
i think we need more than ever right to
be entertained a show-stopping
number sounds good right about now so if
you've never been to a broadway show
i hope one day you get to experience it
i remember the first time just being
like
that i saw i couldn't believe what i was
seeing but there's great entertainment
all around
this country so if it's coming back in
broadway hopefully shows are coming back
where you are as well
and and just go out and support it and
there's such a variety it's not just
musicals now you have kind of every
single box to check as far as what you
could be looking for
on broadway so your tastes will be met
which i love totally and it just feels
like it's just an
incredible thing to see these reopening
reopenings after such a challenging
year but you know there may be one
silver lining of 2020.
many people say this year made them into
a
better person good news network reports
a new survey of 2 000 americans found
that 64
said the struggles of 2020 made them
actually more aware
of others 41 said that they actually
helped a stranger
across the street 31 walked a neighbor's
dog just to help
and listen to this stat a whopping 87
said that they donated money from their
paychecks even though three out of five
people
experience financial hardships and this
just
goes to prove the power of humanity
don't you think
um there's this sign i saw recently
and i can't get it out of my head and i
really want to share it with everybody
um here it is it comes from an instagram
account i really love el arroyo
restaurant in austin texas here's the
sign
ever notice that 2021 is pronounced
2020 yeah
i do believe with all the catastrophe
that happened that we can't even begin
to
be sensitive enough but to see
on the other side of that coin that the
polarity
is that people have stepped up in ways
that they simply were not doing before
that to me makes me feel like 2021
in behavior optimism possibilities
new ways for us to live and treat each
other
and i just love this
sign and it's going to stay with me for
a very long time
by the way it's also a great instagram
account to follow because they do
everything from like super profound
to just straight out funny why am i the
only naked person at this gender reveal
party
do people who run marathons no they
don't have to
i don't have my ducks in a row i have
squirrels and they're at a rave
it's a funny company and i just i love
the account so you should follow them
well guess what drew what the people at
arroyo
are sending the love right back to you
what yes they made a sign for you
drew unto others as you would have them
drew to you
surprise
you made it big time oh my god this is
such a cool surprise
i love you el arroyo i've been following
you all year and you've brought so much
joy into my life
and i can't believe i'm on your side and
by the way
wow cause you you guys know humor but
this is like funny and
cute and like heartfelt yeah oh gosh
thank you oh my god i'm on the al arroyo
side
i knew you'd love that drew and by the
way yeah do
unto others the way you want done to
yourself and i think that's the good
news about 2020 as we started acting yep
perceiving and behaving differently and
we started
fighting for each other instead of with
each other
and i think we really realized when we
couldn't have each other that we need
each other
yes um so congrats on your big sign and
i love that
i am literally i want to get that framed
and the 2020
i can't believe it thank you guys so
much that is like a huge
huge honor for me oh well i'm happy for
you hey and next we've got some new
dating advice from refinery29
they talk to a relationship coach who
says that while it's important to notice
this is interesting
you know you always look for red flags
in a relationship well they say it's
also important to look for green flags
because sometimes the red flag trigger
it it might be a little too itchy our
little trigger finger right
um i actually had a friend who was just
recently dating was like oh i'm just
waiting for the red flag i'm waiting for
the
the thing that's going to show me that
he's crazy and i thought that putting
that
out there is the worst thing you could
do i agree because you're like
collecting evidence of
how are you how are you going to do me
wrong well also like you're just a
self-fulfilling prophecy at that point
totally so refocusing red flags and
looking for green flags why is it
working why is this person good
what do they bring to the table that is
beneficial well my best friend nan the
almighty nan
um she used to have me do a lot of pros
and cons lists
oh yeah and i think that a pros and cons
list is a really
important thing to do for yourself and
for your life
and it falls totally in line with the
green flags and
we need to recognize the good in people
instead of waiting for the other street
to drop or
talking about the red flags because i
feel like we're so focusing on the red
flags more than the green
totes but yes and don't ignore the red
flags either
all right because people are crazy out
there i'm just saying it's important to
look at the good stuff but well that's
why you make the pros and cons list
because you're not ignoring the red
flags but you might see
that there is more good than bad yes and
by the way you're not perfect either oh
okay it's true truth bomb
i can't help it i just think people have
crazy expectations when it comes to
others and they don't look
at themselves often enough either we're
all a little suggy
and we need to
um keep our own side of the street clean
um i think relationships should also be
easy and fun and give you a ton of
pleasure but i
i think looking at that balance of the
red and green flags
will help you see where the imbalance
lies
what does shuggi mean sugi is like
yiddish it means crazy
okay good to know and we are all a
little crazy
some of us more than it comes from oh
there you go
thank you for that so sugi is like that
kind of it's
yiddish with flair
thank you okay and finally this is a
very
important story i really find that it's
actionable
and really important information and i
didn't know it so i want to share it
with everybody else
you may already know this but if you
don't this is important
vaccines just got even easier the wall
street journal reports that uber and
lyft
are offering free rides to vaccine sites
until july 4th they've teamed up with
the white house
as part of president biden's goal to
make sure that 70
of the population has at least one shot
by that holiday in uber and lyft
hope this also helps bring more people
back to work
and their apps and it's full circle
really helping everyone and in other
news
vaccines also have been reported that
the cdc
has approved the pfizer vaccine for
children ages 12
to 15 and they're going to start out the
rollout immediately so that summer camps
summer schools summer hangs all of that
stuff
can start to get back to normal or our
new normal
sooner than later so important
information very
important thanks uber and lyft five
[Music]
stars